Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number, which
is two one nine two David P. Here's a caller
asking Why isn't my show about video games?
Speaker 5: Hey, I'm a big fan of the show.
When I heard there was a David Pakman doing
a podcast, I was hoping that you would be
talking about Miss Pac-Man patterns or Pac-Man
patterns, right? Ah, miss Pac-Man strategies.
I can't imagine having the name Pac-Man and not,
you know, making it a basic part of your identity.
Sure. Maybe. Yeah, I love your show or what
you're doing with it, but maybe talk about
Pac-Man a little bit. I don't know. I think you.
Speaker 1: Yeah, no. That's certainly an idea.
The entire show could be about the video game
Pac-Man, you know, growing up. It's actually
good that now there's a generational change where
people aren't aware of this as much. When I was
between 10 and 18. Any time anybody would see
my last name, it was, Oh, did your dad invent
the video game? And I started saying yes, but
it sort of started to fade away a little bit now
because I guess I mean, I guess the game's just
not that popular or something, but I guess worse
comes to worse. I can always turn this show into a
video game show. If news in politics doesn't work,
it's good to know it's a possibility. We
have such a packed bonus show for you today.
There are Russians protesting the invasion of
Ukraine, and they're protesting it in Russia,
and hundreds have gotten arrested. Hundreds of
people arrested just for protesting in Russia.
FIFA is not yet ready to ban Russia
from the upcoming World Cup in Qatar,
but they have decided that the Russian team
will not be allowed to use the Russian flag
and they will not be allowed to play the Russian
national anthem as punishment for the Russian
invasion of Ukraine. Does this make sense or does
it not make sense? We're going to talk about that
and ah, t- television. Russian state media around
the world, they exist in Canada, the U.S., etc.
R.T. has been demonetized in the United States.
Artie is getting removed from a Canadian
cable system. Our friend, Farron Cousins and Mike
Papantonio have pulled their show from Artie.
What is next for Artie? We're going to talk about
that on today's bonus show as well. I would love
for you to become a member at join Pacman dot
com. We are experiencing a bunch of people there,
kind of like in the tool. See all left. Glenn
Greenwald, Wing of the Left If you believe that
those people are on the left, they're coming
after us hard and the they've been canceling
memberships. Some of them actually used to
support our show and because I've said this
alt left stuff is bad, it's really, really bad.
They've started to cancel memberships and they're
trying to hurt us financially. And that's OK.
I don't want I don't want their money. I don't.
But I would love it if you came in and said,
David, actually appreciate what you're doing on
the Ukraine Russia issue a sign up at join
Pacman dot com. It's really cheap and you'll
also get access to an extra show every day called
the bonus show. Alex Jones hates the bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
it makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah. You'll also get The Daily
Show commercial free six hours before everybody
else, so sign up at Join Pacman dot com. We'll
see you on the bonus show. Tomorrow will have
a new show, a new bonus show and will be live
for Joe Biden, State of the Union.
Unidentified: So a big week ahead.